samedi l'animateur marc olivier fogiel
était l'invité de l'émission on refait
la télé sur rtl il a fait des
confidences à ces folles il a révélé
qu'il ya 20 ans on l'a forcé à perdre au
jeu que le meilleur gagne a présenté par
nagui
tout ça parce qu'ils n'étaient pas assez
connus et inconnus c'est fou hein
regardez et vous allez dire ce que vous
en pensez après il ya un point pour
castaldi me retrouve là et manque de bol
comme je connais la télé j'arrive en
finale face à gérard holtz et là je
réponds
il y avait détruit de rapidité que c'est
un et puis ça bug la machine bug une
fois bon donc ça s'arrête on arrête le
tournage bon on remet à notre question
sa robe bug deux fois on arrête le
tournage c'est un bug trois fois est la
productrice directrice des programmes de
france 2 vient me voir
écoute tu veux bien perdre s'il te plaît
parce que le gagnant ne peut pas être un
inconnu donc j'ai perdu et gérard holtz
a à gagner mais je crois qu'il faudra
encore là vraiment gagner la question
est ce que vous avez déjà assisté déjà
des prix des jeux ds que ça vous choque
t est ce que ça vous délichoc mais ça me
choque absolument c'est très grave c'est
un vrai scandale parce que ça remet en
question tous les jeux télé
si la triche et à ce moment là on peut
tricher partout même si si même ici au
nom pas aussi que si je peux tenir
moi ça m'arrivera pas mais c'est
clairement une situation qui a pu se
passer dans les années 90 mais qui est
impossible à revoir en 2010 trop de
scandales a pas marché c'est que vous
avez plus je crois que je crois que
c'est je crois que c'est pas possible on
recommence pas je crois que c'est pas
dit voit qu'on peut pas tricher je crois
qu'il ment quand il dit ça on pensait
vraiment bien
alors marc willemant part je connais
sûrement pas mais je pense que c'est
trop grave et chettia faire mais bon
quand il n'y a pas un enjeu d'argent il
n'y a pas la lie à perdre et des
arrangements et moi même sur tf1 j'avais
fait qu'ils votent demain à castaldi
ouais avec une championne de lutte et
c'est fou ça le président est simple
premièrement je vous ai mis un point
deuxième manche 2 points ayant fait au
bout de combien gagnez 100 milles il y
avait cent mille euros et est au bout de
cinq étapes
j'étais largement devant et honnêtement
en plus j'étais môme où le produit de
leurs sites et médias n'évoquent et on
m'a demandé de laisser gagner des
candidats plus bas - fruit d'une
technique
une technique smc que vous envoyez des
questions depuis la régie suffit
d'appuyer sur un bouton pour envoyer une
question si j'ai envie de favoriser
bernard et que je vois que la question
qui viennent très compliqué je vais pima
la question aux pauvres suivante qui est
qu'elle est la capitale d'espagne et si
je veux plombé et isabelle je peux aussi
j'en vois une phase il passait derrière
c'est facile de passer de certaines
questions
voilà ces petits arrangements comme
c'est un pur jeu vous faire un croquis
de ce que voulait dire
question difficile mais une question
d'armes sur le soleil sur exactement on
sait qu'il va rêver c'est hallucinant
qui sont en train de nous dire ils sont
en train de nous dire casteliers courbet
qui sont qui était avant ce soir de
grand animateur des magouilles et vous
êtes c'est au tessin vous le savez vous
qu'il avait triché
alors je me suis dit c'est possible je
divorce a exigé que c'est possible mais
on veut dire les vérités c'est pas que
c'est possible c'est que tous les jeux
télévision aujourd'hui en france c'est
pas possible dans d'autres pays parce
qu'il y avait un drame est un scandale
en amérique en france quand vous prenez
les missions de questions le cartouche
et vous avez là vous avez deux
possibilités effectivement et julien a
parfaitement raison soit vous d'envoyer
une question qui vous semble plus facile
que l'autre et si vous connaissez les
spécialités des candidats évidemment
évidemment que si vous ne voulez pas
qu'ils repartent avec la grosse star
balbouli barrière surveillés bellamine
galles on lui pose que les questions
oui bien sûr je suis ni un toit qui a
animé de nombreux jeux tu l'as déjà fait
alors le seul jeu où il est impossible
de tricher
après surface de jeu de questions le
problème et je vous irez vous n'êtes pas
obligés de me croire
c'est que quand vous animez vous savez
pas ce qui se passe en régie je suis
allé passer en régie le producteur la
chaîne dit ça serait bien que voilà vous
vous animez il est question les haricots
un terme et je sais pas ce qu on veut
montrer qu'on peut changer bien sûr et
c'est moche très moche ouais
julien c'est bien de le dire bien que
tout va bien celui-là pour un bravo juju